i'm eddie wu and welcome to education
live i've been speaking with people from
all walks of life
and about how mathematics is connected
to their life and their work and this
morning i have the great joy
of being joined by my friend and food
extraordinaire
alice sasuke alice thanks for joining us
eddie woo good to be here
now alice is really important before we
get stuck into things to start off by
recognizing like right now
you're speaking to us from melbourne and
we have
so many thoughts going to you and the
entire community there indeed across
victoria it's like an incredibly tough
time so ex
extra special thanks i guess for taking
the time to speak with us
thank you we are the canaries down the
coal mine so
learn some lessons and don't do don't do
the things
we are doing our best now alice usually
i start off by giving our viewers
like a bit of an introduction to our
guest but it's actually
a really incredibly difficult task to
introduce you
because you wear so many different hats
and you've done so many different things
throughout your life like you're an
author podcaster
tv host creator in general um
one of the most recent things i've
enjoyed watching you in is your role as
culinary correspondent for the abc so
because you've got so many different
feathers in your hat i'd love to start
with something that you and i share in
common
which is that you began your
professional life as a teacher um
what did you what did you teach well i
was the like you i was the head of my
department so i was the head of the
humanities department so history
geography for middle school so i was
teaching all the way from grade five to
year eight which i'm sure
some of the viewers are in right now and
i was an english teacher as well so
and year eight homeroom teacher and i
still you know it's funny because that
was
sort of in the um
2010s and i've not dated too closely
exactly but uh my students are now in
their 20s and they you know reach out to
me on socials and they're just like
they still call me missy which i love
that is very very cool
now you said 2010s before um one of the
things which has
helped you become sort of uh across the
public awareness
certainly is the first place i
encountered you was in 2012
i think it was you went on masterchef
now
i know from you mentioned your sort of
humanities um area people might think oh
you're a teacher not like a food
technology teacher um i should point out
you didn't
just go on masterchef you got into the
final four
of your season so i guess i would love
to know why did you enter
like what were you aiming to achieve
well i certainly wasn't aiming to leave
you know just before finals week but it
was kind of um
it was funny so when um
i before i went on masterchef i was
always trying to encourage my kids to
find opportunities to weave food into
what we were learning and that's because
i not only found that they um enjoyed it
because they were engaged more but
i also found that the the knowledge and
food literacy was lacking so that was
kind of my
hook but also my opportunity to give
them some life skills that they would be
able to walk away with forever and the
place where i was doing a lot of my own
learning was also the place where the
masterchef auditions were taking
uh place and so i ended up auditioning
because i thought that if my kids see me
on the show for like an episode or two
then they will um maybe want to learn
more about food with me
so that was um as as technical really as
it got or as forward thinking as it got
but then i did a lot better than i
expected so
you know doors started opening and i
thought well i'm here now so what can i
do
and i wrote on a piece of paper teacher
but bigger
and everything that i've done from that
point was always
you know with the eye of a teacher and
the skills of a teacher because
the skills are very transferable but
also
in a way that kids and grown-ups listen
to
that's incredible no i love that and
it's brilliant that you know
having also been on tv but still wearing
that teacher hat i think it's funny that
like you it's about a love for helping
people learn that i think is amazing and
of course a lot of people are masterchef
everyone's got their different reasons
for getting on the show and i'm sure
some people
like their goal is to start a restaurant
but i just love that all the way through
that your heart was about well what's
going to give me a bit of street cred
with my students if i you know gets
and you were incredibly successful and
australia really did fall in love with
you from that point on
even more so than before now food right
is something which it's really
interesting to me that you mentioned
like you said the literacy
like understanding of uh nutrition and
how important that is
is something which is it's pretty low
across australian culture like i
remember
growing up and thinking about like your
your plate of food and having the
different
quantities of different food groups and
kind of i thought all right that's
it's in my brain but if you asked me
about that after that lesson was
finished i was like
i know i meant to have lots of veggies
and that's kind of all i remembered so i
definitely
lacking in a lot of areas and i realized
okay i've got a lot to grow here right
now my mum she loved cooking and one of
the last gifts she gave me and my
siblings before she
passed away a long time ago was a book
of family recipes that we had all grown
up
enjoying so if it's got a really
sentimental place in my heart as i think
it does for
many but um cooking isn't just emotional
it's also mathematical like because you
are a great cook
i understand you have to be across a
bunch of
numbers and measurements could could you
help us understand how does that matter
when you're preparing a dish
yeah well it's funny you mentioned you
know food literacy i think nutrition is
a very small part actually of the way
that we should understand food there's
so much more to it there's the
context there's the culture there's the
geography and the history
there's also the language of food there
and
there are the numbers of food and you
know the science of food so
i think it's funny at school maths was
certainly not one of my favorite
subjects i did it because i had to
all the way through to year 12 um
because i wanted to get into a certain
course but because i was doing it
begrudgingly
i actually ended up doing worse than i
needed to get into the course
i know but you know it's funny because
the course that i would have done had
like
a shiitake load of statistics and
numbers as well
so i feel like maybe the universe was
saying listen you'll get there and it's
because the course was marketing
management psychology so
what i do now if you think about it is
i'm marketing vegetables to the world
i'm managing myself and my own business
and i'm also using
a lot of psychology and principles of
psychology and psychoanalysis and
and you know behavior consumer behavior
insights
to do what i do so that's kind of a good
lesson in life right you you will get
where you want to go you might just not
take the direction that you want it to
but what i also didn't realize is how
much i would end up using
maths in what i do now but i think that
i have an innate
sense for maths um and that's because
standby
my tell you what
tech we would this would not be
happening if we were doing this in one
room but
of course it's cool i like it you know
video better it's very cool
um my parents are both academics they're
both professors and my mum
actually has a mathematics degree so wow
and we should point out as well
for the viewers even though you have
your beautiful australian accent you
were born in georgia and from like
former ussr it's kind of like yes you
know you you must have the mathematics
this is something which is
non-negotiable right like that whole
migrant background is a real thing right
absolutely and i was at russian school
every sunday so we had like extra maths
there um in fact two lessons so there
was like the math theory but also maths
history so looking at the different
mathematicians
it was wild anyway all of that it is
epic but it's informed what i do now and
again
it's kind of it becomes muscle memory
like riding a bike right so
when i'm um you know the maths of food
so where do i begin
i mean there's measurement so something
as simple as looking at a recipe
especially for baking it's really
important to be precise so using
measuring tools whether it be like a
measuring jug
which is um you know understanding that
one cup
is 250 ml and then understanding that
it's also eight ounces or you know
it's different um cup measurements you
know the proportion so you've got to be
doing like all of these conversions
and ratios all the time right all the
time and
one thing that i really love about
measurement of volume in particular is
that one cup of water
weighs the same so weighs 250 mil
and it's one cup always so that's i
think that's
just a really cool gig and it's cool
that like there's that
um there's volume and then there's mass
and then there's like it's all fitting
together just like you're saying food is
connected to all these different
key learning areas and all the rest
exactly and i want the kids to know that
like you probably know more than
grown-ups because we do forget this
stuff and
i remember a few months ago i did a
recipe for news breakfast where i had
cup measures and volume measures as well
and i had
an email no two emails from grown-ups
saying that
i gave incorrect measures because the
cup was 250 grams
but then the cup of flour was 150 grams
and how can that be
it's just it's like it's fine us
grown-ups we actually you're right we
sort of regress a little bit when we
stop using those skills
but it's great like i mean i suppose
when you're picking up a recipe for
example
like most of the things especially when
baking um i do not have the skill yet to
sort of improvise my way into
a cake or some muffins or something like
that but that that recipe is not going
to be measured precisely for me
it's for what someone wanted to prepare
and it's like oh but i want more or less
of that so you've got to do all of that
number crunching yeah
exactly and let's say you've got people
coming around for dinner so you've got
four people coming around for dinner
you've got four courses
you've got certain amount of plates on
the table you've got a certain amount of
ingredients that you need to buy
that's an algebraic equation where
you're solving for x which is like your
shopping list
that's really good yes i've been in that
exact problem so many times where i'm
kind of like oh
in fact just on the weekend i had my
sister over and her family and
there's four of them there's five people
in my family sometimes we might be
joined by others and then it's kind of
like
wait wait a second like i'm going
through the aisles and i'm looking at
these bags of different things and i'm
like how do i make sure like it's the
ultimate shame
to have not prepared enough food for
everyone but then i don't want to be
eating
leftovers of the same old meal that i've
cooked for the next 15 days
so can you can you actually walk me
through that a little bit like i don't
cook meals that are super complex like
you were talking about courses before
can you talk me through like some of the
practicalities if you were throwing a
party
right um how do you make sure what's the
thought process in your mind of trying
to balance out all those different
things and like you said sort of
solve that problem and thread that
needle well you kind of think about
who you have there so kids might be a
half portion
to grown-ups so let's say you've got two
kids and that's one grown-up portion
and then you would think about let's say
for protein like meat fish tofu
you would do like a palm sized amount
would be enough for
grown-ups so half the palm size for kids
and a quarter palm size for toddlers
that sort of thing so it's still very um
still very physical and concrete for me
but for chefs they get to a point where
they think about it in gram weight so it
might be a 220 gram weight
of fish so on masterchef where we had
group challenges where we were cooking a
lot of food we had to make sure that we
had enough food for 500 people let's say
so we would work our way backwards so
this is how much we have
and then would we use bodmas is that
what we're doing yeah sure
absolutely yeah so we'd say okay so
that's how many eggs we have for our
omelets
and then divide that by the 500 people
that are coming to the shangri-la for
their buffet breakfast
how many of those people will want
poached eggs we we're doing a lot of
guesstimating as well
right so um and as you say i think the
biggest problem that a cook can have is
not cooking enough
so i'm always cooking extra and i think
the skill
comes when you start to think about what
you can do with the leftovers and i
love left rings i make extra on purpose
because i love
doing different stuff with the leftovers
the next day so
i don't know what that is is that
carrying the one anyway it's like
all of these i'm thinking about like the
addition or multiplication of
flavors it's a whole different idea
there and i think about
like you've just sort of made my brain
sort of realize that
um obviously cooking in my own home is
one thing and yeah there's you've
mentioned
ratios measurements um you know all
these proportions and that kind of thing
but i've always found it amazing that if
if say for example someone
ran a restaurant and they kind of i can
pick out
anything on the menu pretty much and
they can say yeah that's right
i guess they had to do some kind of
prediction about you know patterns of
how many people they're gonna get who
ordered this or that or the rest right
totally and what uh you don't know about
restaurants is that a lot of that stuff
is really actually just leftovers
because you're doing the prep
all the all the way through the day and
then you're reheating and you're
kind of assembling on the night because
that's what service is all about and
it's a real rush actually
professional kitchen service is just
like wash because you want to do
everything really fast
and i guess it's kind of like maths you
know the more you do it the faster you
get at it so the first night of service
you might be a little bit sloppy but
then
you get quick and it becomes like a
dance really yeah yeah
for sure and there is the chance that
you don't make enough of something and
then in the kitchen we call that 86 inc
so you 86 that
off the menu when you run out yeah okay
all right it's like
code blue or something like that okay so
exactly like that right now
numbers like 86 i just wondered really
quickly
do shapes or geometry figure into
cooking very much
of course they do think about baking
where you're
always baking cakes in different tins
and a lot of baking recipes will tell
you
bake this in a 22 inch tin or bake this
in a 20 inch tin or whatever
and if you use a different size tin then
you need to think about baking time
because it's going to change
you know the density of your cake or the
shape that it's that it's made
is going to change how long it takes in
the oven so a lot of bakers get to a
point where they don't think about the
cooking time they think about the smell
so you're using all of your senses you
know the look so you can see the
bubbling away of the cake batter
in the in the tin until it's ready to go
and obviously putting a skewer through
is the traditional test
um but here's a tip for everyone that's
watching don't wait till the skewer
is clean because that means your cake is
actually overcooked
oh it'll be dry right because if it's
completely clean coming out it's like it
hasn't grabbed anything
okay all right exactly this explains why
my birthday cakes are never really a hit
alice
86 that okay
now alice we're coming towards the end
here so i mentioned before
that you're an author um you've actually
got a new book coming out in november
which is
beautiful in praise of veg super excited
about it um can you tell us what's
what's the message behind it
the message behind in praise of fair
just kind of like your message behind
math so it's time for us to rethink the
way that we look at vegetables because
there is so much to love about
vegetables they can be delicious it's
just that they're a bit maligned and it
goes back to the way that they are
cooked
right so if you learn more about how to
cook them
in ways that bring out the
caramelization the sweetness the flavor
the textures
then you will learn to love veg forever
and not because
you should eat them and not because
they're you know nutritious or healthful
but because they are actually the
tastiest thing on the plate
and when i was a restaurant critic i was
always looking at what chefs were doing
with vegetables first because
that to me is the skill of the chef what
they can do with a cauliflower or
you know how how good can you get your
caramelized brussels sprouts
those sorts of things and i actually
really think that this generation coming
through the people watching
you have the potential to change your
parents minds about vegetables because
a lot of parents grew up with over
boiled
cabbage and you know undercooked peas
and
and and they actually don't like
vegetables and they're serving them up
because they think they have to
but you could revolutionize the way that
your family eats vegetables
just by having a look at the recipes in
the book and eddie you'll be very proud
the book itself has like a matrix in it
like a vegetable spreadsheet i suppose
oh alice you're talking my language now
so
if you look at it almost like a graph i
suppose it's how much time do you have
what vegetable do you have and then you
know what do you feel like that's so
good
your flavor yeah and so that's kind of
for maths heads
um and i had to use spreadsheets to
actually get my book done
because it was you know over 150 recipes
uh we shot you know over 110 of the
photos of the
dish food on plate we call it uh and the
whole thing's you know close to 500
pages so for someone that doesn't
actually love homework
and has never loved homework i had to
sit on my tools
for months but i'm so proud of myself
you know i think there's one thing
when you create something that's not
just me it's a big team that's come
behind it as well but when you see it i
still haven't got the hard copy of the
book so
but i just can't wait i'm going to get
it in a couple of weeks and i'm going to
be holding it and you will see it so
in praise of veg and when you get it and
when you cook from it
please do tag me and i'd love to see it
i'm so excited and like you said
i think that there's this wonderful
opportunity that young people have
today in some ways um you know in a they
have this unparal parallel
sort of um door opening to them to say
hey actually yeah it's not just
not just because you have to but
actually they're brilliant and we are
we are missing out if we don't
incorporate these beautiful foods into
what we eat and share with our families
and enjoy right 100
and i suffer from fomo in a massive way
so that's why i love food because i'm
always
meeting new foods i'm never feeling like
i'm missing out because i get to taste
something new
and if we cultivate that sense of fomo
with
fresh food then we will never be bored
of what's on our plates
that's perfect all right now alice final
note even though
you're not in school anymore i know you
have and you know you still retain such
a heart for kids
i can see that especially in the
brilliant food resource phenomenon that
you sort of
conceived and created and that's one of
the things that you and i have worked on
together one of those fun things i ever
did
um for the kids do you have one last
message to leave with our viewers about
food or mathematics or both
life in general ah that's a big you know
that's a lot of pressure ready woo to
leave with one thing
but i think what i can say is
we're working on the next phase of
phenomenon at the moment and it's to do
with food and mood
obviously we're going through a really
tough time globally
at the moment with everything that's
that's going on with the pandemic and
just with all the upheaval
but it's a real opportunity for us to
seize this moment and to recognize that
there are some things that we can't
control but there's also a lot of stuff
that we can
so thinking about how much we get out
into nature thinking about how much
we move our bodies because that you know
activates the
good feel good hormones in our brains
and what we put into our bodies when it
comes to food
not just you know don't don't look at
the nutritional guidelines
taste what makes you feel good because
fresh food makes me buzz it gives me a
real
kind of zing and it will do the same for
you
so you know that's just one element i'm
not here to sell you on veg that is 100
not what i would try to do but what i am
trying to say is
that you control what you can control
and
and and what will happen is that over
time just like the muscle memory of
learning
um how to calculate numbers or learning
to understand food
you'll get to a point where you can go
i'm not in the best mood right now
what can i do to shift that that is
perfect alice i think it is just the
message we need to hear
especially a time like this so thank you
so much again for taking the time to
hang out with us in
your beautiful kitchen over there um
take care and um we'll be in touch with
you
really soon thanks everyone for joining
us education live i'm eddie wu
take care see you next time